-You´re going
to see "Hamilton" soon, right?
When are you off to see it?
-Yeah, this weekend.
I´m seeing it for the 27th time.
-27th time. That´s, uh...
27 times.
-That´s correct, Seth.
-And have you felt any dips
in your 27 times,
or have you had
the same reaction
pretty much
consistently through it?
-Well, I cry every time.
You know?
-Okay, yeah.
-It first was in --
At The Public --
I went to see it at The Public.
And I was just devastated by it.
-How --
So, for those who don´t know --
´Cause now, obviously, it´s on
Broadway in a giant theater.
How small is The Public?
How many seats was it then?
-Oh, probably,
it´s like under 500, for sure.
-Yeah.
-I mean, you know...
It´s maybe the size of this.
What is this, 200 here?
-Yeah, this is about 200.
-Yeah, so it´s probably --
It´s almost maybe this size.
That´s pretty much it.
-Wow, that´s amazing.
To see a show that now has
this scope and scale
and also sort of
this worldwide phenomenon,
to see it in such a small place
must have been amazing.
-Yeah, the public has done
amazing things.
Like, "A Chorus Line"
started there, and --
I hope that´s right.
All the Broadway trivia people
are like, "You asshole!" Send!
You know?
[ Laughter ]
I´m pretty sure it did.
Lots of things
start at The Public.
Joe Papp is a hero.
Okay!
Do you see I´m a little edgy?
-Yeah.
-I spend like pretty much 90%
of my waking hours
tweeting hatred
towards this administration.
-Yeah. Well, now,
I want to ask you about this,
because that is
a two-way street,
because Donald Trump
has been, uh --
has been mad at you
for a very long time.
-Over a decade, Seth.
-Over a decade.
-Yes.
-And did it sort of start --
It started from "The View," yes?
-"The view."
-Yeah.
And it´s been really --
We´ve sort of made
the joke on the show
that he´s flip-flopped
on everything except you.
-It´s actually very true.
-Yeah.
-There was Tara Conner,
I believe her name was,
a young Irish lass who was
Junior Miss Trump Atlantic City
Pageant Sexist winner?
And she was downtown,
19-year-old girl,
drinking and kissing a girl.
And it was on the cover
of The Post.
So he held a press conference
right before "The View"
went on live, and he said,
"I just want you to know,
I´ve forgiven her.
This young woman --"
I´m like, "What, is he the pimp
and she´s the prostitute?"
Who is he?
He´s the moral arbiter
of 20-year-old behavior now,
right?"
So then I said,
"You know, some facts
that I just went on Wiki
that were easily accessible
since this campaign began,
that he is bankrupt four times,
that got he all his money
from his father,
and that he notoriously
cheats private contractors
out of their money.
-Yes, and that is all
pretty well documented.
-Simple facts, simple facts.
-Yeah.
-And so you said this
on "The View."
-And he went bat [bleep] crazy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And, uh --
And stayed that way.
-Stayed that way.
-Yeah.
-So, you know,
as bad as everyone feels
and they have felt
since November 8th --
I know, for me, I´ve been
in a severe depression.
Although, I´d like to say,
today, after your show,
I´m going to get
a Bob Mueller tattoo.
-Oh, that´s exciting!
[ Laughter ]
-´Cause I love him!
-Where you gonna put it?
Have you thought about
where you´re gonna put it?
-Right over my heart!
[ Laughter ]
I´m so in love with Bob Mueller.
I want to get posters,
I want to meet him.
-Yeah.
-I just think he is it.
-He doesn´t -- I will --
I´m not --
I don´t want to judge
Bob Mueller.
He looks like a very severe man.
-You think?
-Yeah, he -- You know --
-No, he looks, to me,
like Superman.
[ Laughter ]
Like Captain America.
Like justice has finally arrived
back on our shores!
And we are going
to right ourselves again!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is that too much?
-I will say that if --
if he gets --
if Trump gets indicted,
it would be really great
if Mueller
let you serve the papers.
I feel like --
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I have put in
that request by tweet.
-Yeah.
-And I´m waiting to hear.
But, you know,
nothing really will --
I have to say,
the 55-year-old woman
who lived through Vietnam,
you know --
In 1973, my mom died,
and two months later,
they started
the Watergate hearings.
And I remember,
as a child, feeling,
"Wow, there´s no safety
in my house, and, look --
there´s no safety in the world."
And all of that
came right up when he --
First of all, when he announced,
I was laughing my ass off.
-Same here.
I´d been wrong --
-He was on that
little escalator down
with the fake crowd going.
Like, "Here´s my wife
who loves me,"
and she´s like,
"How do I get out of here?"
You know? Right?
[ Laughter ]
And I just thought
it would never happen.
-Same here.
I´ve been wrong at every turn.
-I said to my therapist,
"You know, I got this new show,
´SMILF,´ but I have to go
to Boston to start shooting
the day after the election.
Do you think it´s gonna be
okay for me to be there?
What if he wins?"
She´s like, "Rosie,
you really have to start working
on your negative loop
in your brain.
He is not going to win.
Every smart person knows
he is not going to win."
That night I was like,
"Listen, you wench..."
[ Laughter ]
I am here,
and I have no Xanax!"
[ Laughter ]
Mommy´s better since Bob Mueller
last Friday.
I love you, Bob.
Keep doing what you do, Bob.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you!
-I´m very happy
to have you back here.
Always a pleasure
to talk to you.
And I really hope that,
based on what you said tonight,
you manage to get one more tweet
out of the president.
-I hope I do, Seth.
And I want to say, honestly,
very quickly,
´cause I know it´s annoying
when people compliment the host.
What you have been doing
has really lifted my spirits.
When I have felt
submerged under the ice,
I turn you on, and I go,
"Look at that smart man
speaking common sense,
making people laugh
and making us believe again."
So, you are a hero.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Means a lot.
Means a lot coming from you.
Such a pleasure
to have you here.